should accept yourself just the way you
are what does that say about who I
should become is that just now off the
table because I'm already good enough in
every way so am I done or something get
the hell up get your act together adopt
some responsibility put your life
together develop a vision unfold all
those manifold possibilities that lurk
within be a force for good in the world
and that'll be the adventure of your
life
[Music]
so what we should have done was note
this is particularly dangerous to obese
old people who already have multiple
illnesses and who are additionally
suffering from vitamin D deficiencies
and they probably had well who knows
what their case fatality rate was but
they're the ones that were particularly
at risk whereas for anybody under 40 who
is fundamentally healthy and reasonably
well nourished it was clearly not worse
than the typical run of the mill flu the
key risk factor is age so for instance
obese obese versus non-obese that
abruptly doubles your infection fatality
rate
every seven years of age doubles it
which compounds right so what you have
is a disease that is a very high risk to
identifiable population we in public
health
adopted this Mantra that we were all
equally vulnerable and the idea was and
the ideology was very simple if we don't
force everyone to take the virus as
seriously as as as an 83 year old person
living in you know with multiple
comorbidities does then they then they
won't comply with the lockdown orders
what we asked young people to do was
immoral we said we essentially said stop
sacrifice your life in order to save
Grandma we weaponize the empathy that
young people have against themselves
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone I have the privilege
today of talking to Dr Jay bhattacharya
who's been a very effective spokesman on
the pandemic front during the covid-19
crisis both imaginary and real Dr
bhattacharya has
fought in the public domain to bring
accurate information about the pandemic
and the potential negative consequences
of lockdowns and other covid-19
interventions to widespread public
attention he is a professor and
researcher
specializing in the economics of Health
Care
bhattacharya received all four of his
degrees an M.A an MD and a PhD in
economics from Stanford University
he is currently the director of
Stanford's Center for demography and
economics of health and aging
bhattacharya came under severe fire
during the covid-19 pandemic
believing as he did and publicly
communicating that fact that mask
mandates and forced lockdowns were a
detriment
instead advocating for the development
of herd immunity he argued to allow the
healthy and low-risk individuals the
majority of people to continue on with
everyday life and work while providing
protection for those most at risk
only recently it was revealed through
the Twitter files that among others Dr
bhattacharya was being purposefully
silenced on mainstream media platforms
hello Dr bhattacharya I'm looking very
much forward to this conversation today
uh
we met recently at uh Stanford
conference on academic freedom and that
was really that was the first time we
met public I've been following what
you'd been doing for a long time but it
was good to see you there and it's good
to have this opportunity to
to talk through what's happened over the
last three years especially I would say
in light of the well the recent Cochrane
review for example that indicated
there's no evidence whatsoever that
masks were effective in preventing or
even delaying the transmission of
covid-19 and I've watched the usual
apologists try to win their way around
that review but the Cochrane reviews are
pretty damn reliable and they're
conservative too in their claims and are
known for that right I mean the Cochrane
reviews aren't going to come out and say
that masks don't work if the people who
wrote the reviews aren't pretty damn
convinced that masks don't work and so
the fact that that's the case and that
there was evidence about that beforehand
because in the epidemic planning that
predated
the outbreak of covid-19 there was there
weren't credible people as far as I
could tell that really thought that
masks worked even back then so anyways
the tide seems to be turning on the
covid narrative front and that's not in
in not a small measure attributable to
you so why don't we go into that
show us it's a great honor to talk with
you Jordan it was really Delight to meet
you at the conference I've obviously
been following you for a very long time
uh admire your courage uh you know it's
it's interesting because the science on
kovid on the lockdowns on the mitigation
measures on on a whole host of topics uh
we're if you if the public was listening
they would they would hear this idea
that there was this univocal uh uh uh
you know sort of universal conclusion
that you you had to do lockdowns you had
to wear masks you had to socially
distance you had to put plastic barriers
up you had to close schools you had to
do all of these things that the vaccines
would stop transmission of the disease
that therefore was warranted to to you
know force people to lose their jobs
over them all of these ideas were so
were sold as if there was a scientific
consensus in favor of them
that was a lie there was never a
scientific consensus on almost any of
the topics and as you say on mass in
fact the pre-existing narrative the
pre-existing idea among most scientists
before the pandemic was quite the
opposite direction
what happened was a relatively small
group a cartel almost of a very powerful
scientific bureaucrats took over the the
whole apparatus of science at least as
far as the public eye was concerned
dominated the media dominated the
message to politicians and as a result
we had a catastrophic
response to covet and uh and you know
it's going to be paying the cost of that
for a very long time so let's the dig
into that
the current political climate for
discussion to become
conspiratorial right and the idea of a
cartel well that sounds conspiratorial
now I've been trying to think that
through and so
a system of ideas can act like a
conspiracy even if it doesn't make
itself manifest as a direct conspiracy
because a system of ideas has an
internal intrinsic ethos and View and
implications for actions that unfold
across time if you read the gulag
archipelago for example solzhenitson
does a masterful job of indicating how
the consequences the brutal tyrannical
actions of Lenin and stellen were
necessary concomitants
to the or necessary outcomes of the
axioms that were embedded in the
Communist world view they weren't
deviations from some properly utopian
Norm they were exactly what you'd expect
if you put those principles into
operation and I see similar things going
on around us now
let's say on the politically correct
front I don't really believe there's
this conspiracy of politically correct
people who are meeting in secret to
direct the world or though if there was
the wef would probably qualify but I do
think that systems of ideas can act
as conspiratorial agents now in this
case it's more complex though so there's
a cartel who's pushing forward this
narrative and the question is well or a
system of ideas that's generating it and
the question is
well to what end that's one question and
the other question is who benefits now
and then the further question is why
would the media for example fall into
lockstep shoulder to shoulder
cooperation with those who benefit now
we know perfectly well that the biggest
punitive
civil lawsuits ever levied in the United
States were levied successfully against
pharmaceutical companies and the left
has every reason to be entirely
skeptical about pharmaceutical companies
like they have been for the last five
decades but all of a sudden we saw this
massive spin around where everything the
pharmaceutical company said was taken as
gospel and it's very hard to suppress
the suspicions that something like
massive lobbying and and very narrow
profit-seeking were driving this what's
what's your sense of the of the mode
underlying motivation
so so I I completely agree with you that
this what I what I described as a small
cartel was operating in the context of a
very complex environment
and in that environment many people took
advantage of the opportunities provided
to them by by the the set of events that
unfolded
uh but let me just let me defend the the
characterization of this as a at least
initiated I personally blame Public
Health Public Health authorities the top
Public Health authorities in the world
and the top Public Health authorities in
the United States and Elsewhere for the
the the the set of events that that
trans transpired in response and let's
name some names on that front
yeah so like in the United States a
primary architect of the lockdown
strategy was Tony fauci and he now let
me just describe why I think this wasn't
it's not a conspiracy in what in in a
sense that you know there's this like
small group that has nefarious ideas if
you if you look at the decades before
the pandemic happened
there was a concerted effort in the
United States and elsewhere to prepare
for the next pandemic
that that preparation involved putting
in in into into uh you know into
actuality a whole range of powers that
previously we would have said were not
consistent with liberal democracy powers
to close close you into your home to
close your business to close your
schools uh powers to basically force you
to test and isolate if if you're found
positive uh a whole range of uh almost
you know dictatorial powers that would
have been previously unimaginable
the idea was that we are biohazards to
each other
and the whole goal is if we can keep
each other apart during a time of severe
infectious disease threat he will
actually save lives that was the that
was the premise of this and that and
that that it was coming another a new
respiratory virus
pandemic threat now that is actually was
certain to be true we've had respiratory
virus pandemics time after time you know
decade after decade in the 20th century
we had respiratory virus pandemics 1918
of course now is the most famous but we
had them in you know 1957 1968 1976 you
could just keep going on and on most
recently maybe 2009 and this and the
swine flu pandemic
um so there was there was this
infrastructure set up and in this this
sort of ideology among the top
scientific bureaucrats in this country
and elsewhere that because a respiratory
virus pandemic was coming we needed
better tools than we previously had to
address it and for them the better tools
meant essentially the dictatorial powers
the authoritarian powers that that
constitute a lockdown
uh and they the they uh now when covet
arrived and we can talk about what the
you know exactly how it arrived but
let's just let's just take that as a
given that it arrived that entire
infrastructure sort of powered into
existence
and uh part of that infrastructure
involves making sure that the the people
take the measures that are being
proposed seriously that the threat
seriously
and the way they did that is by
spreading panic and fear about the
disease
in that environment what happened was
that a small group of people
at the head but Tony let's say that's
the same names Tony fauci
uh he dawned on himself the mantle of
science itself
right we're all looking yes he took a
guru he took the name of Science in vain
he actually did and he talks about it as
if it's some sort of uh it's social
religious system
um uh so he he uh he took and what he
did is he he uh designed a a set of
policies in ethos that said if you do
these things then I will rescue you from
the threat that that is going all around
you that's in the air everywhere where
even your children are a biohazard to
you a threat to you
yeah and in that so when that that that
set of events unfolds like you you have
someone who essentially takes over what
truth is in the minds of everybody
then all these other actors could come
in and start to to to say you know if
you mentioned the pharmaceutical
companies they jumped in not I don't
think they're in a nefarious plot I
think that they jumped in legitimately
saying okay let's help figure out how to
address this threat now then they took
advantage of the power they had in very
abusive ways but that's a that's a
that's a layer of development rather
than the the driving force I think and
so how do you understand
the practicalities of the relationship
between the top Public Health
bureaucrats and the pharmaceutical
companies because there's obviously
moral hazard there one of the things
that struck me is really beyond
comprehension in some fundamental sense
is that the Biden White House for
example is essentially a shill is acting
as a shill for Pfizer constantly the
Biden White House tweets out uh around
Christmas for example this became
particularly egregious these constant
reminders that if you loved your
children you'd go have them both
vaccinated and boosted and by that time
it was absolutely clear to me and I'd be
more than happy to be corrected on this
front that the evidence that vaccinating
children was a good idea was not only
lacking it was the best evidence was
counter evidence is that children were
basically at zero risk for uh serious
consequences serious side effects from
kovid and the vaccines in all likelihood
posed a greater threat to them than did
the virus and so I couldn't understand
at all
why the White House would be supporting
the marketing efforts of the
pharmaceutical companies now there are
tens of billions of dollars at stake
here and there is a revolving door and
people who are listening and watching is
my understanding is that there's there's
something of a revolving door in
Washington between powerful companies
and The Regulators who regulate them
those regulatory bureaucratic positions
aren't necessarily particularly well
paid and they don't last forever and a
lot of the people who occupy those
positions are ambitious and there's
nothing necessarily wrong with that but
it's pretty damn useful to have to hire
someone to work for you who was once
involved in the regulation of your
company let's say so there's plenty of
moral hazard on that front how do you
understand the interplay like the
dynamic interplay between the public
health officials quote who are there to
protect us and the and the these
entities operating behind the scenes who
you know do make products that are
useful but also have a
an iron in the fire that isn't
necessarily completely aligned with
everyone's best interests
companies aren't just selling products
anymore they're selling you we're
talking about how these tech companies
enrich themselves by taking your
personal data they grab your web history
email metadata and video searches to
create a detailed profile on you and
then sell that off to the highest bidder
when you go online without a VPN
internet service providers or isps can
see every single website you visit they
can legally sell this information
without your consent to ad companies and
Tech Giants who then use it to Target
you when you use expressvpn your
identity is anonymized by a secure VPN
server so isps cannot see your online
activity your data is also encrypted for
maximum protection
expressvpn is incredibly easy to use
just fire up the app and click one
button plus it works on all devices so
you can stay secure on the go secure
your online data today by visiting
expressvpn.com Jordan that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-svpn.com Jordan and get
three extra months free
expressvpn.com Jordan
yeah so I I think in the idea is that in
war a lot is possible and ethically
permitted that was not would not be
permitted outside of War right so that
this the same kind of principle attack
applies here so what you have for
instance is in again in the US that a
former head of the FDA was actually on
the board of Pfizer
he then is uh on national TV all the
time essentially pushing a line that
benefited Pfizer and its and uh and the
sale of his products uh sometimes and
often in fact without disclosing the
fact that he has this conflict yeah you
know so so they're they're definitely
but you know that's long-standing right
you understand that that that that that
those kinds of conflicts exist and
you're absolutely right like the
Regulatory Agencies there is this like
just sort of people people work for the
regular agencies and then they go work
for the drug companies and come back
right that's like the FDA that's a major
problem the FDA in the U.S faces
um so now that's that's completely
understandable what has to happen is
policy makers top policy makers
understand that Dynamic and act against
it
instead what happened was that the top
policy makers said to maybe to
themselves assuming they acted this way
that that kind of dynamic actually helps
the public
because what they're doing is putting
forward a product that's going to rescue
us from the pandemic yeah we have a
product that's this this vaccine and so
it's okay I mean it's implicit at least
that's that's my interpretation how
people acted
um because otherwise you would have had
top policy makers uh and top Public
Health officials decrying these
conflicts of interest this this sort of
revolving door as you say well the
problem is is that in the face of an
unspecified threat it's easy to make the
argument that The end justifies the
means and you can understand how we
would fall into that especially given
and this is something else that's very
interesting to contemplate the
exaggeration of the severity of the
threat now I've been thinking about this
biologically you know I did a lot of
work on the uh extended immune system
the behavioral immune system and so we
have an immune system that operates
within us to protect us from disease but
we have a behavioral immune system too
and uh both discussed and fear are part
of that behavioral immune system and
what I mean by that is well we tend to
be disgusted by such things as let's say
rotting food and the reason we're
disgusted by it is because the rotting
fruit food is full of bacteria that
produces toxins to keep us from eating
the bacteria's food and we're sensitive
to that so we stay the hell away from it
and so that's part of what defects uh
protects us against pathogens and uh
discussed is is one of the main
mechanisms whereby that operates and so
what we saw happening was the use of
fear definitely but also the use of
disgust which by the way is much more
dangerous because if you're afraid of
something you avoid it but if you're
disgusted by something you burn it and
destroy it so if you start to leverage
disgust in the political landscape
you're playing with fire certainly what
the uh the the Nazi propagandists were
very very good at using disgust and
Hitler's anti-semitic language for
example is absolutely permeated with
disgust metaphors you know purity of the
blood purity of the race the the
Cockroaches and insects that were
conspiring against Germany it's all
Purity language and so I I kind of think
that what happened from a biological
perspective might be construed as an
overreaction of the behavioral immune
system right so you know if if you get
covid you can have a cytokine storm
which is an immune system overreaction
and that can kill you not the virus but
the immune response and in this
situation what happened was we faced an
uncertain threat and then we had as you
pointed out a pre-prepared response to
it that turned out to be far worse on
virtually every front than the threat
that it was purported to to reduce but
that metaphor of a you know of a
extended immune system over reaction
depoliticizes it to some degree you know
we can think about that as more
something like an existential threat
which is how do we regulate our
responses to unknown threats so that the
response itself doesn't become more
pathological than the threat I think
we're facing the same thing on the
climate catastrophe frontal at the
moment by the way and you know people
can differ in their opinions about that
but certainly systemic overreaction is a
constant
potential catastrophe and then we rush
to imitate a totalitarian state too
which was extraordinarily interesting
all across the West in a mad panicked
herd-like
response to well to what that's that's
not what we're learning yeah
I mean I I completely agree I think you
are that's it's actually quite
insightful to point to disgust as as a
central driving Factor uh in this
pandemic right so for instance if anyone
would were to get covered the first
thing you'd ask is who gave it to you
yeah right as if it's um some sort of
sin it's treated not as a disease to be
managed in a person who gets it to be
cared for instead it's a sin that you've
committed that you that you uh and and
as a result and you and once you have it
uh everyone around you needs to be so
far away from you that there's no chance
of the the contagion spreading to them
um I mean now it is true there are
diseases that are quite deadly and you
want to have quarantining I mean those
are like those are legitimate tools
uh but to deployed at a society-wide
level
for an extended periods of time
essentially destroys the underpinnings
of Civil Society we have we made we when
we are are in community with each other
we implicitly accept that that there's
some risk of your spreading some
diseases to me that's just normal part
of of how civilization works it's a deal
we've made with each other civilization
tempers the inclination that we humans
have toward disgust
and and and uh transforms it into into
something where we're much more
constructive
um and and you know you can absolutely
have have pathologies of societies where
that disgust is allowed to spread and
marginalize people like so like you know
I come from in the Indian culture the
Indian Indian societies struggled
forever with this this distinction of
clean and unclean with certain cast of
people being I mean so I mean I think
that is a normal feature of societies
yeah well there's good work too on the
political front showing that societies
where infectious disease prevalence is
higher like genuinely higher are also
substantially more likely to have
authoritarian political structures and
that there seems and the correlations
like 0.7 this is not a trivial effect
it's a walloping effect and and some of
that has to do with well exactly what
you're describing which is which is the
the distinction the ritual and even
sacred distinction between what's clean
and unclean and that does tie into
bodily and physical Purity and then into
a kind of metaphysical Purity and it's
very difficult to keep those levels of
analysis separate I mean the goal of
Public Health has always worked to to
counteract that right right we tell
people it's not you shouldn't moralize a
disease you shouldn't treat a disease as
if it's it is it's something that's neg
like morally wrong about the person that
has these with HIV we learned that
lesson I thought yet during the pandemic
Public Health authorities leaned into
this they leaned into the idea that
someone who gets covid has committed a
sin
um it and you know they didn't say it
out loud but they acted that way
um it's now I said that there was a a
pandemic uh
template but you know that pandemic
template is at odds with every other
pandemic that we manage in the
respiratory of our support advisors
pandemic we manage the last century
right in that whole of the last century
what we did is we identified who was
most at risk
develop Therapeutics vaccines to and
other methods to try to protect those
people as best we could while the
pandemic was was spreading and but
minimized this the fear in society at
large minimized the disruption to the
society at large and the reasoning was
so compelling the idea is that if you if
you disrupt Society
at large you will do more harm to people
than you would save them from the
whatever marginal risk from the from the
respiratory Vice pandemic and spreading
right yeah well that's a basically
conservative so to speak a classic
conservative concern right which is
twofold one is to stress the law of
unintended consequences is this is
something I really learned as a social
scientist and well and and as a
biological scientist for that matter
don't be so sure that your stupid
intervention will only do what you think
it will do only the good things don't
even be sure that it won't be positively
counterproductive be certain that it
will produce unintended consequences
because it will
um you know one of the most famous
studies for example ever done on the
prevention of anti-social Behavior among
kids this was the Somerville study done
back in the 1930s one of the first
large-scale Public Health interventions
on the psychological front
um they grouped kids who were prone to
conduct disorder and then criminal
behavior let's say later in their life
and randomly into a treatment group and
a control group and they hit the
treatment group with every positive
psychological and sociological
intervention you could manage literacy
training parent training communication
training for the kids they paired them
with mentors and they took the kids out
of the inner cities and out to camp
summer camp
for two weeks every year while the
program ran and when they released the
results
it showed very clearly that the kids in
the treatment group
who would be the subject of all this
positive attention which by the way the
kids love the parents love the teachers
love the the implementers loved they did
worse on virtually every measure
and the conclusion was that it was a
really bad idea to take anti-social kids
out of their environment for two weeks
in the summer and group them together
because they were basically camps for
criminals and that was such a powerful
effect that it overwhelmed all the other
interventions Somerville study very very
famous uh cautionary tale and Joan
McCord who was one of the authors of
that study
um and one of the first female phds in
criminology basically spent the rest of
her life traveling around to academic
conferences telling people do not assume
your idiot intervention is going to work
build in careful outcome analysis to any
social program that has a behavioral
change mandate and uh and and
and have some humility in the face of
the complexity the problem you're trying
to solve and certainly well we just let
all that go by the wayside in this now
you said that we had a different
strategy in place for pandemics in the
past and that this new strategy emerged
like emerged where and why did it
dominate
uh I mean I think in the west it emerged
out of the the war on terror you know
the the if you you can go back to the
anthrax threat from I think it was 2001
or two
um and uh and people reacted to that by
saying we need a a way to deal with
biosecurity threats
a new way to deal with biosecurity
threats that's much more serious that
takes the the threat more seriously uh
it they there's a whole series of War
games and uh you know sort of planning
exercises around biosecurity threats
that's not normally what you think of
how you deal with respiratory virus
pandemics right uh you would normally
deal with them the old way which was
focused protection of vulnerable people
development of Therapeutics reduce
making sure that people don't panic
right those you know so Society can go
on as best it can
um I think that that does so when when
uh the pandemic hit in 2020
uh in the U.S
and the world the what happened was that
um the World Health Organization
organized in in the early days of the
pandemic a uh uh a junket if you will to
to China the Chinese authorities in
January 2020 had locked and had declared
finally a pandemic had locked down their
their uh you know this major city Wuhan
yeah and uh
uh that those U.S the World Health
Organization sent a junket that included
uh you know a deputy of Tony fauci uh
prominent officials within you know
Public Health officials the World Health
Organization
um they came back from that junket
saying that what China had done had
worked yeah these authoritarian measures
that China had taken shutting people
into their apartment locking the door
um essentially like had worked the
disease was gone yeah um yeah well you
know lots of lots of dim-witted Western
intellectuals go to communist countries
and conclude that it works
we certainly do we certainly do and
anybody dim enough to go to China under
the control of the CCP and assume that
their top-down authoritarian policies
are working really needs to think a long
and hard about how they view the long
Arc of History let's say I mean the your
default that your default presumption
when dealing with the CCP is 100 of
everything you see is a lie until proven
otherwise
I mean there's an email from Cliff Lane
who's a deputy of Tony fauci he comes
back from this this world this world
technical World Health Organization junk
into China and he's in the email he
writes uh that that we have a we have
what China did work in fact uh what we
have a very difficult decision to make
it will take more than just the people
in this room to make that decision and
he writes what China did work albeit at
Great cost oh yeah that that pesky
little uh what would you say consequence
but you know uh you you mentioned you
mentioned this this uh classic social uh
social science study the expertise of
social scientists was was denigrated
early in the pandemic
the question was are you an
epidemiologist are you a virologist are
you a infectious disease specialist yeah
and anyone else with any other expertise
was not relevant to decision making only
the science itself
how to say right oh well and then as you
said the sign like the science follow
the science it's like well okay what do
you mean here exactly because there's
always a balance of risks if you're a
sophisticated thinker it's like even if
there's a pandemic
um well first of all we better make sure
that there is and that we know the scope
but there's a hundred other
considerations of risk that need to be
simultaneously evaluated and the way to
protect yourself from that cognitive
complexity if you're a a narcissistic
leader and you want to you know Forge
the moral pathway forward is just to
demonize anybody who adds any complexity
into the argument
so we saw plenty exactly what happened
yeah that's exactly what happened and
anyone who has the notion of the law of
unintended consequences of trade-offs of
risk management in their soul or in
their training at least they were they
were excluded from the conversation
right so you could say look uh This is
Gonna really hurt the economy and then
what the response you'd get was well you
care more about money than lies yeah
yeah and therefore you shouldn't do that
but you know the irony is that that the
economic harm from the lockdowns with
100 certainty killed more people and is
still killing more people oh yeah then
the lives say by the lockdowns which I
think are very few yeah well we're not
done with that yet we have no idea how
many people the lockdown and the
associated Panic killed that'll unfold
over
probably decades yeah well especially
when you factor in things like the
decrement and educational attainment
that emerged as a consequence of the of
the suppression of schooling because
that's a whole that's a whole lifetime
of decreased economic productivity
we'll be back in one moment first we
wanted to give you a sneak peek at
Jordan's new series Exodus
so the Hebrews created history as we
know it
you don't get away with anything and so
you might think you can bend the fabric
of reality and that you can treat people
instrumentally and that you can bow to
the Tyrant and violate your conscience
without cost you will pay the piper it's
going to call you out of that slavery
into Freedom even if that pulls you into
the desert
see that there's something else going on
here that is far more Cosmic and deeper
than what you can imagine the highest
ethical
Spirit to which we're beholden is
presented precisely as that spirit that
allies itself with the cause of Freedom
against tyranny I want villains to get
punished but do you want the villains to
learn before they have to pay the
ultimate price that's such a Christian
question
I I can't tell you how frustrated I was
about this so I I my training is it is I
have an MD in a PhD in economics I do
health health economics for a living
I've been following for the last two
decades this this literature
obsessively documenting the returns to
education on the health of children
during their entire lives
and and you know it's it's pretty
convincing it's a great investment we
make when we educate our children in
terms of you know they live longer
healthier more fulfilling lives if and
even like small small interruptions the
education is what the what the
literature documented yeah have a long
lifetime consequences someone uh this
guy named Dimitri kastakis who's a
editor of Jama Pediatrics did this
really interesting paper we just
extrapolated that existing social
science literature and said well we
closed schools for a short time in in
Spring 2020 well consequences will that
have on the lifetime lifespans of
children and he estimated that we had
essentially robbed children in the
United States of five and a half million
life years just from the short
Interruption yeah in March of in Spring
of 2020. well you know schools closed on
the on the basis of Public Health this
cartel of Public Health people all
around the world yeah in in Uganda in in
India the schools closed for two years
many people Don don't have access to
Internet or electricity or whatever that
meant no school and millions of kids it
also meant no social interactions it
meant way more time online it meant way
more time frustrated it it it yeah
depression yeah wanted one in four young
adults seriously considered suicide in
the U.S and according to a CDC survey in
June of 2020. I mean the the
consequences are just the knock-on
consequences were devastating a hundred
the the UN World Health uh world food
program was yelling as loud as it could
that there were going to be Millions
tens of millions of people on the brink
of starvation as a consequence of the
economic dislocation caused by a
lockdown supply chain disruptions
absolutely yeah yeah yeah
yeah and the you know the pointy end of
the supply chain disruption is some some
guy who makes five dollars a day or ten
dollars a day of income selling coconuts
to to Rich Mumbai you know laptop class
and that people and then he loses his
job he now earns less than two dollars a
day of income his family starts that is
that is the that so it wasn't it was
never lies versus money never it was
always lives versus lives and if you
talk to any competent social scientist
that's exactly what they would have told
you uh in that in that early early the
early days of the pandemic so when did
you entirely when okay when did you
start to become concerned about the the
overreach of the pandemic mandates and
and tell me that story and how did that
unfold
um so uh the the day I heard about the
lockdowns uh-huh I mean I just I was I
was absolutely floored I couldn't
believe that that in medicine and public
health we were recommending this
approach that I knew with certainty was
going to harm the lives of poor and
vulnerable people literally everywhere
in the world I thought I thought that we
had made commitments to to protect you
know you know almost these Rosie and
commitments to you you you uh you you
structured uh public policy so that you
don't harm the least the the least
capable among us to to just suffer from
that right
the most vulnerable right
that's what I thought exactly and I
thought okay well that's that's the
that's the profession I thought I was in
yeah and then when when the lockdowns
were announced I mean actually I had an
argument with my with my my boss who's
like it was a in the in in Stanford
medicine
um
almost that very day because his his
wife is the head of Santa Clara County
Public Health and we had this argument
about whether lockdowns were a good idea
on the eve of the lockdown I I just came
away stunned like this can't and I
actually gave a interview to a Reuters
reporter who's doing a story on what
lockdowns would do to kids uh to to
domestic assault rates alcoholism
depression
yeah and so I gave it I gave an
interview in like April of 2020 uh and I
emphasized these knock-on effects I said
they were certain to come and I actually
said in that interview that the
lockdowns were very likely the the
biggest Public Health mistake we ever
made oh yeah you think it's a bigger
Public Health mistake than uh than a
inverted food pyramid and the and the
injunction to everyone to do nothing but
eat carbohydrates till they weigh 350
pounds or
I mean those you gotta admit doesn't at
least compete for for their their a lot
of sins to to weigh but this is
certainly it's certainly up there yeah I
mean you know just in terms of the
catastrophic harm to poor people um yeah
that's not we're not done with that so
everyone listening and watching needs to
know that the catastrophic consequences
of harm done to poor people are still
unfolding and God only knows what the
end result of that's going to be because
food is more expensive than it should
have been and energy is more expensive
than it should have been and there are
multiple reasons for that but the bloody
supply chain disruptions were one of
them and we really toyed with bringing
our supply chains to the brink of bloody
disaster it's still hard to buy a car in
North America and you know it's really
difficult to screw something up like
that because we're pretty damn good at
making cars and so and distributing them
and to see that there are shortages on
all fronts for rich people you just
imagine what the shortages are like for
poor people
so so yeah you know the other thought I
had very early early on was that we
didn't actually know how deadly disease
was right right so in this one during
the swine flu epidemic there had been um
the early estimates by the World Health
Organization was that the case fatality
rate was four or five percent yeah just
like they said with covet yeah but what
happened in the swine flu epidemic in
2009 was a whole bunch of Scholars ran
studies called zero prevalent study
studies of of measuring antibodies in
the blood of populations
antibody specific specific to the to the
to the you know the flu virus that was
floating around and what they found was
there were a hundred times more
infections or more than cases because
the the virus had produced a mild
reaction in some people generating an
antibody and they didn't go into the
doctor no one knew that they that they
had had the flu yeah um or had the swine
flu and so the the infection fatality
rate turned out to be 0.01 percent
okay so that had already been
established as a scientific president
what do you think the case fatality rate
was for covid
so I ran a study in April of 2020 a
Serial prevalent study in Santa Clara
County California and now we didn't
include nursing homes
um we're much we're the really high case
infection fatality rate actually is uh
but if you include in the community it
turned out to be about 0.2
99.8 survival and we ran another
separate study in LA county the uh the
week after and found almost the same
identical
infection fatality rate and how does
that compare to your standard flu
well you know that's funny because you
ask that because I don't know I I looked
like the people say that the flu has a
0.1 infection fatality rate uh but I
don't know that's true it's not backed
by careful serial prevalent studies so
for instance the swine flu which was
thought to be particularly deadly turned
out to be 0.01 right right
um you know one order of magnitude so I
I do think that those more deadly than
the flu there's no question in my mind
impact about that and that was no
question in my mind from the very moment
I heard about this this was something to
take seriously absolutely that point two
percent while much less than the three
or four percent that the world health
organizations panicking people are with
was still a very high number and it's
especially high for older people right
if you can think about it as like the
the risk doubles by every seven years of
age so you know I was 51 at the time
uh my mom who was 82 or 81 at the time
uh like what's that what is that like
one two three four doublings uh my
infection fatality rate was 0.2 percent
hers was you know
0.4.8.1.6 3.2 percent right right so the
proper response would have been to to
identify that the genuine risk factors
for for serious risk of hospitalization
let's say And as far as I can tell these
are what they are and I would also
appreciate being corrected so age is a
major one obesity is a huge contributor
um comorbidity that hardly counts
because of course the more morbidities
you have the more likely you're to die
of anything but that still has to be
taken into account and then I've also
concluded that uh the evidence for
increased severity among people who have
vitamin D deficiencies also seems to be
quite robust and so what we should have
done was note this is particularly
dangerous to obese old people people who
already have multiple illnesses and who
are additionally suffering from vitamin
D deficiencies and they probably had
well who knows what their case fatality
rate was but they're the ones that were
particularly at risk whereas for anybody
under 40 who is fundamentally healthy
and reasonably well nourished it was
clearly not worse than the typical run
of the mill flu does that seem about
right
yeah I mean I think I I might modify the
statement about the relative risk of the
flu because I just don't know what that
is but I I think it's a very very it's a
very low risk for for relative for
healthy young people
um and I think and I agree with you
about the risk factors but the the key
risk factors age so for instance obese
obese versus non-obese that roughly
doubles your infection fatality rate
every seven years of age doubles it oh
yeah which compounds right so like so so
so what you have is a disease you know
like 80 of the deaths are people over
the age of 65 still
um so what you have is a disease that is
a very high risk to identify low
population and for the rest of the
population and the vitamin D I agree
with actually although that's some a
little bit controversial I I don't know
why it's controversial this seems to me
that the evidence is pretty clear on
this in any case there's no harm
accessible and harmless how about that
impossible exactly that's another
problem so you just tell people to go
out and have and have exercise like what
yeah I mean instead of being locked at
home and not being able to go to a park
for example exactly so like that so like
like having that as a as a modifiable
risk factor would have been healthier
would have produced health for other in
other ways as well right um so it's
instead we
we we in public health
adopted this Mantra that we were all
equally vulnerable yeah that so if I
remember uh watching this uh this press
conference by this uh this Rudy gobert
was a National Basketball Association
Player NBA basketball player in the
United States
and he'd contracted covet early in the
pandemic and yeah you know he's a young
man very healthy uh didn't appear to
have to be particularly sick but he gave
his press conference where he like just
was joking around he licked the
microphone right he was making fun of
the clean and unclean Trope that was
starting to like spread and the the
whole world came down on this poor man
it forced him to apologize you know uh
and and you have to take the virus
seriously even young healthy NBA players
who are at basically zero risk from
dying from this disease
I have to I'll grovel and apologize
because they're acting like young
healthy people it looks like discuss
demonization a that particular response
it absolutely is and the idea was the
ideology was very simple if we don't
force everyone to take the virus as
seriously as as as a 83 year old person
living in you know with multiple
comorbidities does then they then they
won't comply with the lockdown orders
what we asked young people to do was
immoral we said we essentially said stop
sacrifice your life yes in order to save
Grandma we weaponize the empathy that
young people have against themselves no
in order to produce a small decrement in
Risk to Grandma but you know that's the
funny thing it didn't really even
protect Grant right right still over the
age of 65. yeah you have a disease that
spreads very very easily uh and the
lockdown measures people can't really
comply with them for extended periods of
time except unless you happen to be very
well off and have a job that can be
replaced with uh with a with a laptop
right
um then then okay maybe but that's a
very small fraction of the the world
population yeah uh maybe 20 30 percent
of even the of rich countries right
right okay so you started to become
aware of this back in in March of 2020
right away essentially as soon as the
lockdowns occurred and so and and you
talked about the first conversation you
you had with one of your colleagues who
was involved in local public health and
you could see this miasma of paranoia
and force spreading and it was very
concerning to you because of your
epidemiological and economics training
and the economists at least are trained
to consider well multiple trade-offs in
terms of value if they're good
economists obviously they seem to be
more reliable public policy formulators
by and large I would say than biologists
who take a much more uni-dimensional
view of the world and the
epidemiologists as well who specialize
in a given illness so so then
as this marched forward what did you
find yourself doing well I mean there
was a lot of I I published these studies
or wrote These studies on Sierra
prevalence published them and there was
a tremendous blowback
my colleagues didn't want to believe the
result they thought it was a much more
deadly disease than we were finding with
our with our scientific studies
um and actually stand
I was as where we met was the Stanford
academic freedom conference I told a
little bit about the story about how
Stanford treated me which is I think
abysmally
um yeah well let's let's delve into that
a little bit because that's par for the
course at modern universities as well at
the moment so what happened you you
published these studies now we should
point out to everyone who's watching and
listening that Jay is not exactly your
Fringe researcher right Stanford's a
major university he has a PHD in
economics and an MD it's a very very
well respected researcher and certainly
not someone who's prone to grinding
political access and that's generally
the case for epidemiologists and rail
scientists is they're not politically
minded they're trying to as much as it's
possible to follow the trail of the data
and I certainly believe that you're in
that category so you publish these
papers showing what was good news
essentially this isn't as deadly as we
thought and you produced a counter
immune response from your call
colleagues and so what did that gets
consist of I mean I I got I got accused
of of not knowing how to divide
essentially not knowing how to divide
doing the math wrong that that there was
still a possibility that every single
positive result we found on these
antibody tests were all false positives
and then I started getting hit pieces
against me against my wife against
against like you know my colleagues
um I mean it was it was it was very
stressful it's never reacted to those
hit pieces in the Press by giving them
Credence even when they didn't when they
knew for a fact they were false so for
instance there was an allegation that
that uh that somebody that that the head
of the of a airline company had given
five thousand dollars uh to me and to to
and somehow I changed the result of the
study but it was ridiculous the five
thousand dollars went to Stanford in a
gift account we used to offset study
expenses we ran this study in two weeks
or three weeks uh we organized it and
ran it it was you know it was really a I
mean quite a feet right and we demand it
very inexpensively
um
I would never alter the result of a
study
to for based on what funders say it's
ridiculous and what benefit would that
be to you anyways like if you're going
to convict someone accuse someone of a
crime you should at least have a motive
in mind and if five thousand dollars
pretty cheap price for your soul by the
way Jay and
um and then and then like what's in it
for you exactly what what was the
accusation you were falsifying the data
for what reason
yeah so I mean so Stanford rather than
just dismissing the allegations out of
hand they they they conducted but first
they started to call it an investigation
but then they realized they couldn't
call an investigation it was so
ridiculous they called it a fact-finding
issue oh one of those
yeah and like I I spent that summer just
incredibly stressed yeah I've never felt
I'd never felt anxiety before I mean I
I'd never really not bad before I just
was a scientist Jordan I wrote I
published papers for a living in
peer-reviewed journals I was really
happy with that life yeah yeah but join
the club man
yeah I know I thought about you a lot
actually in those days Jordan
um and and I I and I I uh I had to make
a decision
um you know after Stanford cleared me
they'd set this very strong signal if I
just went back to their whole life
did you know just quietly doing science
they would let just let me go they'd
continue to be a good uh you know good
faculty member and stand good you know
faculty member good standing right so
despite the fact that you were innocent
you should shut the hell up and go back
to invisibility and then we'll let you
what what we'll we'll so what are the
powers that be decided as long as you
were compliant and quiet like a good
faculty member should be then all the
sins you didn't commit would be forgiven
yes exactly how lovely and that's so
impressive and he was it was so
stressful Jordan I I mean like I said I
thought about you a lot when in those
days because I know what you went
through
um but you know I lost I I generally am
very good at dealing with anxiety I've
never in my life it felt felt anxiety I
felt it in a deep way I I lost 30 pounds
of weight yeah I at one point I was
losing weight so quickly I couldn't I
thought I was actually afraid for my
life
um yeah I I was um I I couldn't sleep I
could I didn't eat I just obsessively
worked trying to like address the damage
um and then some point at some point in
like summer of 2020 I decided that you
know what is my career for
it's not if it's just to like have a you
know another CV line or a stamp it's
just I've wasted my life yeah
um and I that I would I would speak no
matter what the consequences and
actually then the anxiety went away like
at that at that point
that decision I think was the right one
people have two big classes of fear
and they're archetypal and one is fear
of Nature and the other is fear of
culture those are good ways of thinking
about it and you're afraid of nature
because you could die you could go
insane you could lose your mind you
could die you could die while you're
suffering that's worth being afraid of
second category
you'll get mobbed excluded and alienated
and then you'll die and so
when and I've watched this with like 200
people now who've been mobbed and
betrayed by the by the well by the
powers that be let's say and every
single one of them with tiny exceptions
responds exactly the way you did which
is it's as if something
traumatic in an unprecedented manner has
occurred and I've seen colleagues of
mine who were well you said for example
yourself you weren't particularly prone
to anxiety you know fairly emotionally
stable person I've seen people
colleagues of mine who were the most
solid people you could possibly imagine
like literally hounded into the Asylum
by the by the mo by the forces of the
mob it's appalling this this this this
this
demonizing Council culture driven by
narcissistic Psychopaths it's like it
could be the death of us all it's really
bad and so your response is absolutely
typical it's interesting though eh when
you you make that decision to flip the
what would you say to flip the the to
invert the reality to go on the
offensive rather than to be defensive
and guilty then while that especially if
you are basing that on a genuine
apprehension of your own instance that
does change the playing landscape
substantially and so that happened to
you when that was in the summer of 2020
yeah sometime in some I talked to my
colleague a friend of mine uh who was
I've written with many times who sat
inside and told him explicitly I'm
Crossing the Rubicon I don't I don't
care about my reputation anymore I what
I you know my whatever academic
reputation I'm going to use what
knowledge and uh and uh you know sort of
resources I have to say what I believe
yeah because I think that were there
many many lives at stake in the mistake
mistaken uh policies we've adopted and I
have the had the background and the the
you know sort of the the the the
um the life story where I could actually
try to make some difference on that
right right after that it was it was
just transformative I mean I you know I
also am religious and uh you know
praying actually helped a lot but that's
the summer what were you praying for
just out of curiosity at that just just
for just just for clarity for what
relief from the the anxiety uh and then
Clarity for what I should do with my
life
yeah well you know one of the things
that
there is nothing that will save you in a
complex situation except the truth
now it might not save you
as well but there is nothing else that
you have and so when you're backed into
a corner well first of all you better
scour your soul but second what you've
got to defend you if you have anything
is definitely words of truth words that
you believe to be the case and so and
it's useful to notice that that can be
on your side and you know you have to I
don't know the other thing I realize is
if I'm living my life just for myself
it's Hollow
uh if I if the purpose of my work before
I mean you look back on my work uh I
what I wrote when I applied for tenure
was that I was I studied vulnerable
populations the health and well-being of
vulnerable populations and how
government policies and economic uh
economic uh realities affect the health
and well-being I mean and if that if
that's true that means what I studied
was for other people yeah that my
actions and my when my was was done
inwardly focused but focused on on on
the the the people that I studied right
well so that means the crisis also
forced you to really prioritize your
values you know because and It's Tricky
as a scientist you know when you see
this when you're training graduate
students is that well you have to follow
the science properly and you have to be
skeptical of your own results and you
have to be sure you're not publishing
merely so that you publish
and merely to burnish your reputation
and the same thing with attending
conferences on the other hand you do
have to publish and you have to Market
and communicate there is a there is a
career development element to every
Enterprise now the question then becomes
well what do you do when those are set
at odds with one another and the answer
is well if you're
tilting towards pathological narcissism
you sacrifice the mission for the
message and there's plenty of corruption
in science that's merely a consequence
of that but when you're backed into a
corner the way you were then you have to
really start to understand what that
means it's like are you in this to do
the good that hypothetically motivates
the science or are you going to
sacrifice that apologize kowtow and
hypothetically protect your reputation
and that's you're done as a scientist if
you do that I think you're done as an
ethical actor I think you're done as a
human being you are and you don't
protect yourself against the mob because
all that's happened is they've they've
fundamentally emasculated you and you've
been eliminated as a as a credible
threat it's a very bad strategy so well
so it's a relief to hear that you
you know we're able to see your pathway
forward in in the summer I'm sure that
was utterly brutal it's it's hard to
communicate to people just exactly what
it's like to be a respected scientific
practitioner and then to have all of
that inverted and to see your colleagues
fail to support you or participate in
the inversion it's quite the it's quite
the illuminating experience let's put it
that way yeah yeah yeah I guess I
understood how I understood how the how
excommunication works right right
exactly that's what it felt like yeah
you bet because that's that's that
betrayal and excommunication that's
exactly what it is so then okay so you
decided
to
yeah that you were the devil take the
hide most and that you were gonna say
what you needed what you believe to be
true and so what occurred then
so fast forward a few months I I there
was some uh my colleagues got Atlas was
advising the president United States and
so I actually got to meet with the
president there's but but that that
never went anywhere the the American
president at the time president Trump
um he was uh I think his instincts were
against the lockdowns but his his uh he
basically thought that if he if he
lifted if he let Tony fauci not have the
the Reigns that he would lose the
election
um and so you know that was quite
frustrating fast forward a few months
October 2020.
and a colleague of mine from Harvard
Martin cooldorf was a fantastic
biostatistician he helped design the
vaccine safety surveillance systems that
statistical systems that the FDA and the
CDC use in the U.S uh with it with the
statistical work invited me and sunetra
Gupta who's a great epidemiologist at
Oxford University to a small conference
in Great Barrington Massachusetts yeah
we arrived basically just to compare
notes like we weren't thinking about
issuing a statement or anything but we
realized that we'd arrived at the same
place regarding the strategy of how to
manage the pandemic the the summer had
seen a decline in cases there's some
some spread in like Arizona in the South
and some other some countries but the
the threat of March seemed to have
subsided but it was really clear from
the data that the disease was coming
back in the fall that there was going to
be spread of the disease again and and
it was also clear to me as a social
scientist looking at the pattern of
political uh that the lockdowns were
also going to come back because the fear
was not gone the disgust was not gone
all of that was still in place all the
infrastructure for the lockdowns were
there
and so what we we wrote this very short
document one page long
um called the Great Barrington
declaration it we wrote it in very
simple language because we wanted to
reach regular people because I I thought
to myself and we thought to ourselves
that it was really regular people that
needed to know that there wasn't a
consensus in favor of the lockdown yeah
that people were being misled that the
idea that all scientists agreed that
there was a consensus that the science
said let's lock down was not true in
fact many many reputable scientists
disagreed with that and yet they stayed
silent because of the fear of of social
ostracism fear of you know Tony facci
controls billions of dollars of of
federal money on for research
um that what's not just the money so you
can do your experiments it controls a
social status of scientists you know you
don't get tenure at a top university uh
Medical University unless you get NIH
funding yeah
um in the United States so it's the
social status as well as even more than
the money itself well it's not just the
social status either we should be clear
about that it's also your livelihood
itself right because so it isn't merely
the fact that you want to elevate your
up yourself up to status hierarchy it's
that you want to keep your job and so
this is this is this is nuts and bolts
this is this is nuts and bolts material
here yeah you know I was very ill when
the Great Barrington declaration came
out so I wasn't as uh what would you say
aware of everything that was going on as
I might have been under different
conditions but one of the things I do
remember and I've been struck by this
continually is that while it was
demonized and put off to the side as the
work of essentially like scientific
Outsiders and extremists and what's so
interesting about that I found this
repeatedly because I've talked to a lot
of reprehensible people over the last
few years such as yourself and I found
that even though I know as well as
anyone how easy it is for people to be
demonized for their views and how often
that's purely an invention of
Psychopathic narcissists very often
trying to score points at the expense of
someone's reputation it's still the case
that even the smallest slur in
relationship to someone's
professional reputation is enough to
make
to make even me skeptical about who I'm
talking to because you think it's very
hard to think
well if there's enough smoke there's
probably some fire right and that's
actually a pretty intelligent rule of
thumb decision because there's seven
billion people out there you're not
going to listen to all of them and so
one way you cut through the complexity
of figuring out who to listen to is you
don't listen to people whose reputations
have been salvaged and you don't have
time to sort that out like a legal trial
you know but but what it does mean is
that reputation savaging can be
weaponized and the and and there are
people who are absolutely Stellar at
that and the Great Barrington
Declaration was definitely Savage
ignored and Savaged both and so so okay
so it launched win and this was in 2020
the October 4th 2020.
um I mean the the uh you know people
that's like tens of thousands of doctors
and and epidemiologists signed it uh
Nobel Prize winner signed it like almost
a million people have signed it to date
um it it would it went viral very
rapidly like we just put it on a web
page and people just found it and I
started getting messages from people
saying you know thanking me for like
saying Common Sense yeah protect
vulnerable people protect vulnerable
people lift the lockdowns that was those
are the two ideas the great Branch it's
the old pandemic plan it's the least
original thing I've ever written in my
entire life I mean there's nothing
nothing new actually in it and certainly
nothing radical
I didn't think so but four days after we
wrote it the head of the National
Institute of Health Francis Collins
wrote an email to Tony fauci
recalling the three of us that were the
primary co-authors of the Declaration
Fringe epidemiology right right
and then he called for a devastating
published takedown of the premises I
started getting hit pieces written
against me in the New York Times again
in the in the Washington Post a whole
bunch of other I mean the CBC hosted a
panel of scientists uh who Savaged us as
wanting to let the virus rip and kill
Graham yeah yeah you know thanks God
Broadcasting Corporation that 1.4
billion dollars of government subsidy a
year and a 1.9 market share they're
quite the they're quite the Stellar
Bunch boy
uh the the the level of propaganda was
remarkable like I I was calling for
focused protection of vulnerable people
I was calling for a conversation among
Public Health people how better to
protect old people who were dying in
droves as a consequence of not being
protected by the lockdowns
um I wanted you know how to how do you
protect all people is complicated right
so it depends on the local living
circumstances of each person of the of
the old people in the community the
answer in you know Alberta uh in Canada
is going to be very different to answer
in in uh you know like in like highly in
in like you know Southern California or
something it's just gonna be very
different all those pesky complexities
yeah well you need local public health
who know the living circumstances to
participate in that discussion
think creatively about how to protect
older people when you have this highly
highly infectious respiratory virus
pandemic going going on
um instead we were demonized we were
told that it was impossible to protect
older people without a lockdown
um that the lock time didn't protect
older people it hadn't in the spring and
it didn't didn't protect them in the in
the fall and did continue to not protect
them uh so so it it essentially they
closed their the the the top of the
federal Public Health bureaucracy close
the minds of Public Health against the
possibility of focus protection by
demonizing us right and the purpose of
the demonization was so that they could
tell the public that that every
reputable scientist the consensusive
scientists agreed with their plan yeah
their plan to lock down yeah well that
and I suppose the motivation for that
was
the ability to publicly trumpet the
Staggering Effectiveness and
decisiveness of their simple and and and
potent plan to protect right and so for
me again that's a kind of unbelievably
narcissistic virtue signaling is you
want all the credit that would go along
with actually dealing with the problem
while doing none of the effort
whatsoever necessary to actually
understand the problem and to implement
the complex multi-dimensional solutions
that would be demanded yeah I mean I
actually I remember
um seeing a podcast with you and your
daughter I think uh during during that
time I was I was quite moved actually by
it both by the devotion your daughter
has to you and also with the the illness
you're going through so I don't think
you have anything to to I mean that you
what you went through is tremendous
um and uh anyway so so uh we uh we wrote
this starting I mean but the thing is I
was emotionally better prepared to deal
with the blowback from that yeah yeah
and and it would it became this like um
this this thing where where it was clear
that the purpose was to limit the reach
of the Declaration many people still
have not heard of it yeah um that
probably should have heard of it
um and and that partly succeeded yeah
but it didn't entirely succeed the
nucleus of this anti-lockdown movement
was was was put in place and then and
then as time has gone on what's happened
is that that anti-lockdown movement as
people have have seen the reality what
the lockdowns really have meant well
lockdowns is not just you know you're
forced quarantine at home lockdown is
the ideology that we must keep people
apart from each other the ideology that
we have to treat each other as biohazard
and that the state has the right to
impose that from the top down right
which is a major part of the ideology
for everyone's good
you know one of the things I also know
knew and I don't know how much you know
about this and maybe you know a lot
about it you know the Nazi eradication
campaign started out as public health
initiatives
like the causal pathway is clear
and so it the and that discussed
demonization was part of that process
but it was all put forward initially
under the guise of protecting the public
and doing the best even for the
suffering so was they the the Nazis were
extremely good at leveraging a false
compassion on the narcissistic front to
produce unbelievably pathological
outcomes and that went along also with
the notion the implicit notion that well
the state has the right to do whatever's
necessary if public health is at risk
and it's whatever's necessary that's the
that's like really whatever's necessary
eh yeah well
um maybe you're well here's my here's my
new Theory my political Theory or part
of it
if your response to an emergency
makes you terrified
and tyrannical and one of the
consequences of that is your claim that
the emergency justifies the granting of
all due power to you
you are not the right leader and there's
three levels of evidence number one
you're frightened into paralysis by the
emergency so you're too small
second you're willing to extend the use
of tyrannical power to justify response
to your fear that's also an indication
that you're not just frightened you're a
frightened Tyrant and third
the
claim that you're making that the
situation is so dire that you and the
people who think like you must be given
all the power is a moral hazard of the
first order and so there's three
identifying features so that everyone
listening and watching can understand
who not to trust in the leadership
position is the emergency terrifies them
they become tyrants and it's so
convenient that they also get all the
power it's like nope those are not the
leaders you want not not even if the
emergency is real let alone when it's
manufactured you know for the benefit of
people who want all the power and all
the unearned credit yeah I mean I I
agree with that I think that that the
people who
um draw power to themselves you you want
you absolutely need to be skeptical at
the very least you want checks and
balances right so like imagine if we'd
had an honest and open debate about
pandemic policy like without this
demonization without this canceled
cancel culture kind of kind of overlay
we would have won that debate Jordan
because it was already clear in October
2020 uh first that the lockdowns have
done tremendous harm we'll continue to
do tremendous harm to the poor the
vulnerable to to Working Class People
um it was all it was already cleared
that they'd failed to stop the disease
from spreading yeah like what success
was there
um and then and then the third it was
already clear who the vulnerable people
really were like the highest risk people
like so at that point if there had been
an open debate without this demonization
the the P the authoritarians would have
lost
the scientific consent I mean I at the
time when I wrote the Declaration I
thought we actually were in the minority
among scientists yeah I'm not sure
that's true actually yeah no all right
I suspect it's probably not true is that
but it's also almost impossible to
overestimate the probability that people
will be silenced by intimidation and we
should be take this very seriously like
look you said
and this is borne out by the experience
of literally the hundreds of people I've
talked to to whom this has happened you
experienced the exclusion and mobbing as
something akin to a life-threatening
illness yeah so it's no joke it's no
bloody wonder that people are afraid to
speak out and could it be the majority
it's like yes absolutely it could be the
majority because it's a minority of
power mad
um narcissists who twist The Narrative
to their uh liking and their or to their
advantage and they're perfectly willing
to take out anybody who stands in their
way and so it's certainly probable I
would think that the more sensible
scientists knew that something was amiss
on the covid lockdown front and we're
very hesitant to step forward and speak
and you can say well aren't they
cowardly it's like yeah maybe wait till
you find yourself in that position see
how Bloody Brave you are because my
experiences being that that kind of
Bravery is
vanishingly rare maybe one percent of
people can manage it
you know and they often have additional
resources that aren't available to
everybody like me to the degree that I
was Brave I suppose I at least wouldn't
shut my mouth you know I had three
sources of income
right so and I lost two of them
but I didn't lose the third one and most
people aren't in a position where they
have established three independent
sources of income so like I lost my
professorship and I lost my clinical
practice but I didn't lose my business
and so and then I also had the support
of my family like full support of my
family and extended family and of a very
large network of friends and so
many many people who are put in a corner
have some of them have none of those
what would you say force is in their
corner and on their side
I mean I I have tenure at Stanford uh I
I wasn't sure that the tenure would hold
yeah I mean they did it was it was it
was not clear to me I don't have I've I
had that one source of income but you
know Jordan I just don't believe that my
life should be lived simply for for that
tenure or the money I I think um I I
lost a major source of support in the in
many of my friends
that I previously called friends I wrote
broke with broke with me yeah
um so I lost that but I didn't lose my
family I didn't lose my my faith
um and what what I found in compensation
was this tremendous community of people
that that saw what was happening and
that that found what I was saying
meaningful to them
I I mean I just it's hard to convey to
people how much that meant yeah right it
would it it could it really it made me
feel like my that what I was doing was
worthwhile probably really for the first
time I mean it's fine to get CV lines
with like you know published papers and
fantasy journals but to actually have
that move people to to to to to to to
action to to give them give them the
ability to to speak up when when
Injustice being done
um that's there's something I just you
can't replace it yeah um yeah well I
guess that's the reward that's the
reward you accrue for having undergone
the the trials of exclusion and mobbing
right and that that that ability to Ally
yourself to the degree that you're
extraordinarily careful and fortunate
with with what you believe to be true
yes and that's definitely something
worth that well there isn't anything
that's more worth discovering than that
some fundamental sense now let's talk
for a moment about you said that you
know the Barrington Declaration was
marginalized and demonized both of those
with some success on both fronts and I
would say yes with some success but not
with entire success and but let's also
talk about how your communication on the
public front was thwarted so I've been
watching the Twitter trust and safety
the former trust and safety executive
Joel Roth being roasted over the slow
fire or maybe a quick fire in congress
with a certain degree of satisfaction
and it's clearly the case that social
media Enterprises and Twitter the most
egregious among them perhaps although we
don't know what happened at Facebook Etc
um
you are definitely persona non grata on
the Social Media communication front and
so what do you make of that and how did
that unfold yeah so I joined Twitter in
August 2021 I mean I I never had a
Twitter presence I in fact I told my uh
assistant professors and graduate
students don't join Twitter just write
scientific papers for a decade yeah yeah
so there was some irony in my joining
Twitter
um uh what I found was that uh that it I
felt like it gave me a voice right I
joined almost I immediately got a
hundred thousand followers it was
actually kind of kind of uh you know it
felt like I could have had a platform
yep
um but you know I would write messages
and it would get attention of my
followers but it never went outside of
my followers
and I I wondered about that
um when Barry Weiss wrote her Twitter
files expose what she found was that the
day I joined Twitter I was put on a
trans Blacklist that guaranteed that
that my tweets and I joined Twitter for
one purpose essentially to communicate
to the public the ideas of the Great
Barrington declaration took to criticize
Public Health when it was warranted to
criticize Public Health to propose
alternate strategies for managing a
pandemic and to help create a community
of people who uh of scientists and
regular people who would then give have
some tools to oppose authoritarianism
where they were
you know public health and storage units
and where they were that was the purpose
of joining Twitter
um and then also to convince people that
didn't necessarily agree with me or just
didn't know my message that that I had
something reasonable to say about the
about these topics
um so to be on a trans Blacklist
essentially what it meant was that I
could not actually even though it looked
to me like I was accomplishing something
with Twitter and I was with my followers
um but I I wasn't accomplishing the
broader purpose for which I joined
Twitter yeah the purpose for which
shooter exists actually I think is to
allow those kinds that kind of
communication to happen at scale yeah I
actually I've said I I have a mixed
emotions about it isn't correct
incredibly powerful tool Jordan as you
know you reach uh political leaders you
reach uh you reach journalists you you
reach other scientists you in a way that
and you reach regular people in a way
that's not possible with any other
platform
um and and
uh I I think it in the right hands it is
a it is a force great Force for good in
society yeah but it's also a place where
like uh what would you call it Penny
anti
um Penny anti Petty tyrants can run
roughshod invisibly behind the scenes
and we certainly see no shortage of that
on Twitter despite the fact that the
Legacy Media uh you know damned their
calloused Souls seem to have no interest
whatsoever on sharing the revelations
that musk has made public about the
unbelievably backbiting maneuvering that
went around went went on underground
continually on the Twitter landscape so
it's really pernicious eh when you're
subject to the authoritarian constraint
of your Communication in a manner that's
actually invisible as well as lied about
it's really something pathological and
so what's your understanding of how your
communication was restricted on Twitter
so I I actually got to go visit Elon
Musk and see Twitter headquarters and
they showed me their they have a system
called jira where you know you have you
have your own account I had my account
and they would have you know sort of uh
marks on my account for like what the
the restrictions were literally said the
words trans Blacklist
um
that Trends Blacklist I don't believe
Twitter put in place on its own I
believe that that was the result of the
American federal government
essentially asking Twitter Executives to
suppress now why don't you say Trends
t-r-e-n-d-s or trans
t-r-e-n-d-s okay yeah okay trans
Blacklist got it yeah so so did that
means we're trending right go on it got
it so that meant you couldn't go viral
essentially anything that you did yeah
uh-huh yeah that's right okay
and you think that there was collusion
between Twitter and the federal
government and this would be the public
health bureaucracy essentially designed
to stop you from being able to
communicate your your expertise let's be
clear about that yeah your expertise so
uh I think a lot of governments did this
but certainly American government did
this they adopted the strategy of
limiting misinformation in social media
settings
yeah
the way they did that is they cooperate
they they they garnered the cooperation
of social media companies by uh
essentially by threat right if you don't
if you don't do this we're gonna we're
gonna regulate you out of existence yeah
uh that started with this like National
Security issues around uh election
election issues and National Security
issues but I think it bled over into
into this pandemic management Russia
collusion conspiracy fraud
um and so and so like you had it bled
over into this into into like
communication about about health risks
and covet right and so like the Surgeon
General the United States had an
initiative where he wanted to root out
information
um Tony fauci has an email with Frank
with Mark Zuckerberg from the very
beginning of the pandemic where
Zuckerberg essentially offers him
it's redacted but from the context it's
pretty pretty clear some capacity to
limit what Facebook actually what you
can post people can post on Facebook to
limit misinformation
um the the ins the social media
companies were in regular contact with
the federal government
receiving instructions about what to
suppress and in many cases who does the
Press yep regarding regarding
specifically uh you know in information
about covid
um and you know I know this because I'm
part of a lawsuit that the Missouri and
Louisiana attorney general's offices
have brought against the federal the by
Administration yeah right and that
lawsuit isn't covered we deposed Tony
fauci we deposed uh I think gen saki is
going to be deposed a whole bunch of
like very prominent figures when is this
going to unfold it's been going on for
like uh nine months now I mean it's
hopefully we'll get some decision in
this coming year
um I'm actually quite hopeful about this
because what we've uncovered they
testified of fauci and Saki testified
yet uh fauci has I don't know yet if you
had sake in yet but there was the the
judges granted us the ability to depose
10 major figures inside the the the the
the buying Administration including
including FBI agents um and others it's
revealed a vast censorship Enterprise
well we should also Define for everybody
who's listening and watching
what fascism means technically so
fascism means to bind together and the
fascist ethos is something like Unity of
Corporation government and media at the
highest levels of of function and so the
idea is essentially that
the uh a triumvirate acting as a Unity
at those high levels can be
extraordinarily efficient and if it's
benevolent
there's the rub then it can March
forward you know with unparalleled
success and you get people like our
appalling prime minister admiring the
CCP for example for its ability to move
forward on the environmental front
without you know paying attention to
such niceties as let's say Parliament
and public opinion and that's that
delusion of fascist deficiency and the
thing about United systems is they can
move very very quickly when they need to
and that's well and good if they're
moving in the right direction but the
right direction is hard to determine and
if they're moving in the wrong direction
then God help us all and this collusion
between the social media uh companies
and the security apparatus and the
broader media World which is still
occurring because they won't cover the
Twitter files is fascist in the highest
order and it's definitely a threat to
the Integrity of well I would say proper
governance worldwide but certainly
proper governance within the United
States it's appalling beyond belief I
think part of the reason the public
hasn't woken up to it is certainly true
in Canada
Canadians would rather believe for
example that the trucker Convoy was run
by Mega inspired American Republicans
who wanted to destabilize Canadian
democracy which is what our bloody prime
minister told them they would ask Jordan
they had bouncy houses they had bouncy
houses for kids I mean they had like
seek seek music and I mean it was like
well there's a huge codery of seek
truckers in Canada yeah well Canadians
would rather believe that though that
this was a conspiratorial Enterprise
motivated really by and funded by Mega
Americans This is the Canadian narrative
most Canadians still believe that 51
percent and the reason they still
believe that is because it's easier to
believe that than it is to believe that
you can't that your your leaders
Christia Freeland Justin Trudeau jagmeet
saying are compromised entirely by their
globalist utopian agenda and lying about
absolutely everything and that you can't
trust the Legacy Media anymore and
Canadians just they're not capable of
swallowing that bitter pill and like I
can understand why you know in our
country and in yours too to a large
degree the fundamental institutions have
been reasonably trustworthy for a long
time and then to understand that no you
have to now go out and you have to go
and ferret out the truth and that there
are
conspiracy-like actions proceeding on
all sorts of domains it's like well it's
no wonder people don't can't go there
with ease yeah I mean I I don't want to
believe it either well right until I
until I see it I I'm gonna I'm gonna
assume the best of of people but when
you see the uh the federal government
acting in this way in direct violation
of fundamental commitments to civil
rights like free speech
um and and you know it's there and
emails in black and white uh where and
you know and and the way that they
conveyed it's it's as if they that it's
so obvious that they're doing the right
thing oh yeah we just suppress this
because we didn't want people to be
harmed by this bad information well how
do you know this information is bad well
that that this is the question like I I
now virtually instantly distrust anyone
who uses the word misinformation or the
word disinformation it's like
I see you you think there's some gold
standard by which factual information
can be revealed
that its validity can be revealed that's
just self-evident you can set up some
fact-finding Community Committee that
can just differentiate between the true
facts and the false facts it's like why
do we need the scientific Enterprise
then if it's so bloody obvious and why
is there political discussion well no no
there's misinformation and we need
committees to to deal with it and to
suppress it which they certainly did at
Twitter Jordan it's an it's a new Dark
Age right that was the that was the
feature of the old Dark Age was that
there was a a high Clarity that could
just inerringly distinguish truth from
falsity and and there and suppress
falsities to for the benefit of the
public at large right that if that isn't
the age we are currently living in yeah
well it's a degenerate it's a degenerate
theocracy right but the uh what running
itself under the guise of a kind of
rampant secularism it's really something
to see and it's so interesting maybe we
could touch on this in a minute I knew
10 years ago that the woke types in the
universities would go after the stem
fields and everyone thought at that
point that I was being conspiratorial
and paranoid and I thought no no I know
how scientists work most of them are
obsessively focused on their narrow
specialization that's not an insult
that's their job that's their job is to
be 80 hours a week focused on that
specific issue to understand it deeply
and communicate that to the rest of us
more power to them but it means that
they don't have a political bone in
their body especially the real
scientists especially in stem and so
when the woke political mob of
narcissists comes for them they won't
have a hope of resisting and well
obviously that's exactly what's
happening in the California system now
ucal system 80 percent of applicants to
stem positions are rejected on the basis
of inadequate diversity inclusivity and
Equity statements you see that Texas
yesterday University of Texas revoked
its commitment to uh to requiring die
statements as a precondition for
employment and then of course denied
that they ever had such a policy in
place to begin with I mean those those
are those are they're just the de facto
loyalty Oaths I mean that's essentially
like you're you're I mean it's a
statement of faith uh that you but you
belong to this particular or you know
faith faith tradition with uh you know
documented by the Dei statements I mean
I I just I think it's it's one of these
things where like I never imagined that
the that the free countries of the West
would come to a situation where
um the the the the you know like the
basic civil rights
um checks and balances of power all
these like Norms of Liberal Liberal
civilization that I thought everyone
agreed with were actually in question I
mean you saw it earlier than most I I
certainly you know before the pandemic
you I would have thought of them as
annoying but I wouldn't have thought of
this as an existential threat and now
I've literally ComEd around yeah yeah
well it's
yeah well the well you know the other
thing we could think about too here is
that
we don't want to underestimate the
pervasive attractiveness of of this set
of ideas I mean it devastated Eastern
Europe Russia and China and and that's
still going on in China it's still going
on in North Korea these are attractive
ideas they promise Universal Brotherhood
they promise uh an egalitarianism that
is not only impossible to produce but
would be horrible in its realization but
that looks on on the surface
extraordinarily attractive they appeal
to a kind of domestic ethos too you know
Ben Shapiro said to me one time he said
well at home I'm a communist
and what he meant by that was that in
his family he has children it's to each
according to his need and from each
according to his ability and that might
work perfectly well in the domestic
environment you know in a limited manner
but as a scalable political Enterprise
it's a complete bloody disaster it's not
obvious why it's just obvious that
that's the case and you know when I grew
up we had this Soviet Union as evil
example of this woke
pseudo-communist ideology and that kept
everybody in check but that threat
diminished substantially in 1989 and it
allowed these ideas to
hold sway once again in the west you
know aided and abetted by idiot
intellectuals especially on the literary
criticism front but that's just pervaded
the institutions of higher education
like mad but we need to give the devil
is due I mean these ideas hold sway over
the minds of hundreds of millions of
people because they offer uh
attractiveness on the utopian front
that's not easy for conservatives or
classical liberals or scientists to
mitigate against with their insistence
on individual autonomy and
responsibility and the importance of
tradition and the necessity of rational
inquiry even communities like so I'm a
big I mean I think communities are
incredibly important like thick
communities where people are embedded
and they they draw support uh uh like
even people who think like that should
be opposed to these ideas because these
these ideas destroy communities we need
to have checks I mean just just couldn't
go let's go back to our discussion about
lockdowns what did lockdowns do other
than destroy communities it's not it's
not an individual thing to set into
individualistic to say uh the lockdowns
are a bad idea they destroy the
communities that provide support for the
poor and the poorest communities most
part well the other thing too is that
look for all you leftists who are
listening all 15 of you
um
and this is why I like people like
Russell Brand and and to some degree Joe
Rogan it's like
why do you believe if you're on the left
that fascist collusion at the highest
levels of of power is going to serve the
communities that you might even rightly
be attempting to serve you know the
genuine left just as I've known many in
my life say labor leader types you know
who are trying to give the a real voice
to the working class and that's a
necessary thing to do and to push back
against the gigantism and excess of the
corporate world that's a valid thing to
do why in the world would you think that
these this top-down collusion between
government state media is in the
interests of the people that you purport
to serve it's a Preposterous notion I
I've encountered many people on the left
like the honest left who joined the the
anti-lockdown movement so natural Gupta
for who wrote The Great branches
declaration for instance is famously on
the on the on the on the on the left
um uh so I I think that there is a
tradition within the left that is
solidly devoted to basic liberal ideas
it's just as there is on the right
there's a and I think that's the
Coalition that will win
um and the lockdowns the whole I the
whole strategy we followed to drive the
pandemic is to at least for me has has
just brought me to a realization about
how how how
unimportant other kinds of political
designations are you know Democrat
liberal Democrat Republic I mean really
the key thing the key unifying thing is
this uh uh you know this devotion this I
this this this this commitment to checks
and balances uh a commitment to sort of
Enlightenment Enlightenment ideals a
commitment to to religious tolerance to
freedom freedom of speech and freedom of
freedom of speech and conscience
probably foremost among those and I
think foremost because as far as I can
tell all the other processes that keep
systems of good governance in place are
dependent how could it be otherwise on
freedom of conscience thought and speech
because that's the mechanism by which
complex problems are solved and so if
you give up that mechanism that's the
mechanism of thought itself and I mean
what we're doing today well both of us
are trying to update our views of the
world to some degree as well as to
communicate with other people but that's
all part of the process of analysis
diagnosis and repair of systems that
have gone astray and unless you can
engage in that freely then they just go
more astray and the consequences of that
as we saw with the lockdown and are
continuing to see with the lockdown the
consequences of that are
well we'll see how cataclysmic they are
you know I thought for example that part
of the reason we're in a war with Russia
is probably perhaps that maybe this is
only 10 percent of the problem or less
world leaders weren't getting together
and talking
because the lockdowns it's like I don't
know how often the president of the
United States and and the leader of
Russia should get together and talk but
never is definitely the wrong answer and
if you think you can do that
electronically and do it successfully
you're naive and careless Beyond uh what
would you call it Beyond forgiveness
beyond the requirement for forgiveness
so and I think it extends not just to
like greatly you know top leaders of
countries but also just the regular
interactions with people like a lot of
the the fracture of of of of of
communities of you know like just take
my like my my own example of like the
friendships that have been broken if
we'd actually been meeting with other
faculty members regularly just because
we ran into them on in the in the in the
office building yeah I just find it hard
to like you would have been much more
difficult to demonize me if I if Francis
Collins or Tony fauci had just called me
and talked and spoke and said here's
what we were thinking here's why we're
concerned let's change this could you
change it do this way you know I might I
might have gone along to like try to
like figure out how to how to
accommodate their concerns like it's
rather than demonizing me we would have
found a better right better way to like
manage I mean science works by those
kinds of personal Communications it's
you know yeah you write papers but then
you go talk to people those conferences
are actually worthwhile because now you
get to know really with who they are
what they what they how they think yeah
it's a human endeavor yeah just just as
you know and and to like to have this
ideology where you have to be a part
will replace everything just by Zoom it
just doesn't work yeah well the the
other thing that's lurking underneath
all of this that we're going to have to
contend with is that
um I think virtualization breeds
mistrust
and so what I've noticed when I've
conducted virtualized Enterprises is
that they go fine
when everyone agrees but they go very
badly as soon as disagreement emerges
and I think it's because if I disagree
with you it's easy for that to produce a
Halo and for me to think well we
disagree on everything if we were
getting together and having a coffee and
bumping to into each other in the
hallway we'd say that it's one minor
disagreement in a host of agreements but
person that requires personal contact
and so that's foregone on the in the
virtual world and then I also think that
this is worse and I don't know how
dangerous the threat it is but I think
it's a Paramount threat I also think
that virtualization enables psychopathy
because psychopaths are actually held at
Bay by The Perils of face-to-face
communication and if they can operate
behind the scenes which they can
certainly do online there's an immense
amount of online criminal activity and
exploitation I mean the whole
pornography industry is nothing but that
and then immense like swaths of
criminals operating online and then all
the troll Behavior as well like we may
be setting up a world in Virtual in the
virtual space that where the Psychopaths
and the Predators and the predatory
parasites because that's what a
psychopath is they can just they can
just run roughshod I mean there there's
a there's a counter balancing so I I
know people that uh that speak
anonymously because where they
legitimately fear their job and they
wouldn't speak otherwise yeah so there's
a temporary so I don't I don't know how
you manage that I don't either maybe you
you authorize it just it's it's a it's a
complicated problem but I I hear you I
mean it is um one of the costs of going
online going on Twitter oh yeah you're
subject to tremendous alumni from from
like random people I don't know but you
know I think that was happening before I
went on Twitter though I mean just in
the minds of some people or the the the
reputation destroying mechanisms of some
people it's just so you just I I view it
as like at least I'm in a position where
I can I can speak and get my message out
and if they're gonna if they're gonna
um you know sort of attack me in this in
these vile ways I just I I at the very
least I can have my own say yeah yeah
rather than staying silent yeah yeah
yeah yeah no no people say things on
Twitter that would instantly get them
punched in real life
and so yeah and they do it all the time
and there are people who do that just
for entertainment and I mean the
clinical literature on that is becoming
extraordinarily clear so the the uh the
particularly pathological Venom spewing
trolls
um you know a small percentage of the
anonymous accounts are genuine
whistleblowers most of them are
Machiavellian Psychopathic narcissistic
sadists and that's what the clinical
literature shows and they have full sway
on Twitter and disproportionate effect
and that's warping the entire political
landscape anyways that's grounds for
another conversation we should actually
wrap this up I guess there's lots of
other things we can talk about but we
covered a fair bit of territory today
and so it's a pleasure to get to sit
down and talk with you at some length we
didn't manage that at Stanford although
we got to know each other at least a
trifle there so uh what's next
as far as you're concerned what are you
attempting to do right now maybe we can
close without
sure so the main thing is uh the the
public health authorities made
tremendous mistakes we can just at least
that at least mistakes uh during the
pandemic uh the public deserves a full
accounting of what decisions were made
who made them and why there needs to be
an honest coveted Commission on the on
the order of like the 911 Commission
that honestly looks at these and answers
these questions so I've been working on
a document called the Norfolk group
document you can figure go to
norfolkgroup.org and find it with a with
a bunch of my colleagues
um where we've set an agenda it's just
questions that a honest covet commission
would ask
um
well maybe we should do a podcast with
like two or three members of that group
when you guys are farther far enough
along to feel that that would be useful
why don't we do that and you could
suggest to me who these people should be
okay let's do that and so any sense
about when that might be uh so the the
document is actually done we've been
working for that on it for the last
eight months and now I want to spend
time educating uh you know willing
legislators and others who are going to
be conducting these inquiries okay so in
in basic in every country like so right
now the next step I think is we're going
to try to translate get it translated
into multiple languages uh and try to
contact uh
commissions that are already starting to
form you know parliamentary inquiries or
right missions are already starting to
form uh so that they have these set of
questions in front of them that they can
ask these are reasonable questions like
you know uh you know what what was the
basis for deciding that uh the children
should have the vaccine yeah yeah I'd
like to know the answer to that so I was
like for sure because I just figure that
out the evidence yeah we just lay out
the evidence today we here's but you
know why wasn't a why didn't the
randomized trials for children for this
vaccine have as a clinical endpoint the
prevention of hospitalization or death
why did it only have antibody production
as as yeah there's a good one like
things like this yeah
to produce all-cause mortality as one of
the outcomes
it's an excellent question because that
would have helped us understand what
what better to do with the the vaccine
yes so I think I mean like any of you so
we have like we have like a just it's
you know on 10 different top why were
the schools closed did what was done to
mitigate the harms of school closure
things like this yeah so questions that
need to get answered the public deserved
an answer
um so and that and the goal is at least
my my goal is not necessarily indict
anybody or anything in terms of like
criminally or whatever my goal is so
that we in public health understand the
right lessons reform repent even yeah
and then so we don't ever do this again
yeah we respect civil liberties next
time that I think the outcome of any
honest process will be that lockdown
will be a dirty word that we will
shudder and horror whenever we hear it
and anyone that proposes it will be seen
as a charlatan yeah and I think that's
that's the that is the ultimate outcome
of of any honest inquiry and I'm gonna
I'm working toward like making sure
those honestly inquiries happen yeah
well Amen to that okay so for everyone
watching and listening I'm gonna I'm
gonna talk to Jay for another half an
hour on the daily wire plus platform I
usually walk people through a bit of a
biographical discussion about how
they're how their career unfolded and
how their interests
their meaningful interests made
themselves manifest in their life so
that's on the daily wire plus platform
for all of those of you who are watching
and listening thank you very much for
your time and attention Dr J
bhattacharya thank you very much for
talking to me today it was a pleasure to
walk through all this I suppose a
strange sort of pleasure to walk through
all this dismal material with you but to
see it laid clear in the manner you
managed it that's that's extraordinarily
helpful and so uh and thanks to the crew
here in
Minneapolis
Minnesota for helping me out today to
make this happen
so good to see you Jay and uh well we'll
talk again when when the Norfolk group
uh project is ready to to uh accrue some
additional uh Public Communication thank
you thank you Jordan a great honor to
talk with you good good to see you
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com